my name is Dennis Collins and I'm giving
the talk on status in life dynamics and
Julius Caesar drama triangle cycling
spaced on their work in my book drama
conflict in history David science than
Australia or that is the book thank you
one of the things that could be
dangerous nowadays is the loss of
democracy due to increasing depth
despotism around the world so the idea
was that in the Roman Empire before it
became an empire there was increasing
conflict of Rome with other places
actually like Syria and there was a guy
named Mithridates who who died in 63 BC
here there's actually a book written
about him because he is able to avoid
poisons and so forth but anyway the
Romans spent lots of times trying to get
him and I think he killed hundreds of
thousands of Romans before they finally
got him but anyway there's a similar
situation in what was said I'm who
saying that he sort of escaped the u.s.
a couple times so the problem is that
within 20 years of the end of
Mithradates
the Roman Empire sort of failed with
Julius Caesar taking over so there's a
problem today of the same thing
happening within 20 years of Saddam
Hussein dying in around 2006 I guess so
that were self so far about our from 6
to 19 it's 3/4 of the way towards the 20
years anyway so it says could the same
instabilities beset the US has caused
the Roman Republic to falter within 20
years of the end in 63 BC of Mithradates
the 6th and lead to a return to the
paternal model of model of politics such
as practiced in North Korea so this was
written in 2009 so we're going to try to
use a central force model to study this
problem it's
if I can get this thing so the status in
life then dynamics is based on a kind of
a logarithmic scale X of distance away
from death so the zero on the scale is
like a person who's dead or has only
minutes or seconds to live like a baby
in a hot car or a person without oxygen
one on the scale is up days hours or
days to live like lacking water two is
weeks or months to live like lacking
food three is just someone who lacks
mobility and freedom like is in a
hospital nursing home or prison for as a
dependent person probably doesn't have
any work maybe no transportation and
might be living in a shelter or
something number five there was a like a
trait change around 4.5 between a
dependent person an independent person
so you can think of a person on a tax
reform like if he's listed as a
dependent it means he's not contributing
that much otherwise an independent
person is like employed he has a secure
source of income he could be some kind
of access to a car number 6 would be
active person he can support a family
and has a mortgage maybe 7 is a
contributing person he has basically
steady income and probably owns a house
then
I'd see I should be walking keep going
maybe let's see what happens here
whoops not so good see if anything
happens if I try to go down this way
okay it looks like all right so um the
first model that I used is the so called
death and taxes model and that's what I
handed out here actually this is from
1872 a courier a knives print but it
illustrates art sort of getting ahead of
math to this extent that you can think
of a death force as being a central
force that pulls the sial or status and
life scale down to zero so it's like if
you throw a ball up in the air and
weight it comes back down it has the
shape of a parabola so this here you can
think of someone who's a baby has a
certain amount of resources when he's
born and he can achieve a certain amount
of success on the si si si l scale so he
becomes independent during youth and
then he's independent for a while and
then when he gets old again he might be
rejected in mobility like being a
nursing home or basically something like
that or a hospital by the way you can
look at the outline of the talk if you
if you want to you can just pass this
around but I don't know how much time
I'll have I don't know if you're
interested in this but anyway yeah this
is an outline of the talk so um I
probably won't have time to do much of
this stuff but anyway huh you can just
solve this F equal MA you probably if
you had any physics at all you know that
our acceleration is a sequel to mass
times mass times acceleration is the
force so the death force here is like
minus four zero zero four five which
works it out and the person starts at
zero
and goes up to slightly above five which
means he's an independent person and
then at age 100 like in this graph he's
back to zero again he dies so then the
next thing we added into that was the
government force the central force so if
I can get this thing to work
whoops so so this is an example the
other one I had k equal to zero that
means there's no government force the
government force can be thought of as a
force that trends to a person told
people to an average of four point five
they're right on the borderline between
dependent and independent so if a person
is making more than more money he has to
do pay taxes and that tends to take him
down on the si es si else
scale also if he's making money by crime
the police can come after him and take
him down on the si SL scale if he gets
put in prison than his si L value will
be less than 5 or 4 less than four point
five like being in prison is like 4 3 on
the scale which for examples had
happened to many people in the u.s.
recently so anyway if the person is
below four point five then the
government usually has some kind of
program or something to try to improve
them so they're not out on the streets
and so forth or if they're a child
abuser the government will come after
and try to help the children and get
them back up to a higher status in life
scale so then now if you do this you're
basically putting in this 4.5 K it
basically is
putting in a term that is positive if
anyway it's - the force is minus K times
X minus 4.5 looking the second line down
there so if X is greater than 4.5 they
will tend to pull the person down if
it's less than 4.5 it will tend to pull
them up so there seem to be a sequence
of solutions of this problem and the
first one actually is
let's see very similar to the parabola
solution it's only slightly different
that's if you put in a 1 here as the
exponent but anyway the one we're
interested in right now is with a 2 so
this will make the value come down to 0
again when you get to a hundred years
old and the picture here if I get it to
work out
Oh
10 minutes left ok so we've got to get
on to the other thing but anyway let's
see if I can get this thing to go down
here all right so
not too good at doing this but anyway uh
somewhere
I guess somehow that craft didn't come
out but anyway what happens is anyway
somehow that graph disappeared but what
happens is that the the graph goes down
to zero at 80 years old and then there's
like a little loop underneath there and
it goes back up to zero at a hundred and
instead of just going up to like five
point six the graph goes up to eight so
basically by having the government there
which will help you get started when
you're like young so we'll pull you up
above four point five you can get us an
SI L value all the way up to eight and
then when you get up above eight it
pulls you down even more because you
have a it's like a spring the government
force at four point five is like a
spring so the more you pull it up the
more gets pulled down and the more you
pull it down the more it gets pulled up
so basically the government force
well maybe caused you to die at age
eighty instead of a hundred but in
compensation for that you'll get to an
SI L value of eight instead of five
something anyway shocks in medicine the
basically whoops I guess there's nothing
left on this so I don't know what
happened to the rest the rest of the
presentation but anyway let's see what
is this ten or eleven but I can explain
this anyway something that happens
usually in my talks I
I probably should go ahead and start
talking about the well shocks in
medicine you can put in a delta function
into the negative and that changes the
slope so if you put in a large negative
Delta function the person will basically
die once you put in that shock like
getting shot or getting getting in an
automobile accident or like happened to
one of the congressmen that had to
resign or something they there SI L
value goes down and the medicine you can
also put in a positive shark shock so
for example on this on this chart here
there's like this soldier guy so I was
thinking of like Horatio Nelson who was
killed at the Battle of Trafalgar at age
47 so basically that's a shock he got
hit on a boat or some on a ship and a
guide but you can ask what would happen
to him today like in modern medicine so
you can have a positive shock that would
bring him back up so if you do that what
you find is that the parabola goes down
and dips down but then it turns out that
you could actually live longer because
when you get decreased the you don't
have the government pulling you down so
far so you can actually live longer
well anyway getting on to the to the
drama triangle cycling I'll try to hand
out some of these papers here is this
somewhat hard to follow without without
having the Pape the values to look at
but anyway it seems like this has gone
off the screen for some reason but
mostly what happens during my talks
maybe I can try pushing this thing over
that might help let's try this I don't
think
it's probably my fault the drama
triangle cycling essentially you can
keep track of the person's status and
life values for each person like an X Y
Z if X has taken as the overall
aggressive her his or her else il value
can move her up or down versus time tip
I guess it's my father they didn't know
how to run this thing correctly
typically starting from a large value
say a effects that the aggressor
basically is usually has a lot of power
so if X becomes a victim his si L value
will become less than four point five
indicating some kind of dependence
Newtonian dynamics can be worked out in
three-dimensional space also with regard
to central forces as in Tenenbaum
pollard book that was in the in the
abstract and so they show that a
possible solution is a
let's see I guess you have to go down on
this side ah there's a circle so we can
imagine you can set up the circle this
you can imagine each one of these things
is like 4.5 long or 13.5 units long so
the middle of this plane will be having
coordinates of four point five four
point five and four point five so that
everybody would be basically at the
borderline between dependence and
independence
so then essentially you can figure out
the equation of the circle because if
you go from the center point to the
vertex that defines like the y-axis for
a circle and if you go parallel to the
bottom line which connects the x and y
coordinates of a straight line then that
can be the the x coordinate or the ya
the X the x coordinate of a circle or in
our case it would be the y coordinate oh
well it would be just sana so you get an
oblique plane with you can make a radius
of five you get a circle so then we're
thinking about what happens as time goes
on which is what's on this chart so this
thing is based on the deaths of the
triumvirate members of julius caesar so
essentially the aggressor is considered
to be caesar so he actually goes up
above 8.5 and then gets goes down lower
the victim is Crassus and he eventually
dies in 52 53 BC when his si L value
goes down to 0.41 so if you don't follow
this it's like a round in music where
each one of the columns follows the same
values
they're just in different order so
anyway he got killed by actually I think
one of the children of the method
eighties as he tried to get more power
for himself anyway then so he's the
victim so he dies in 53 BC but I just
put 52 there then 48 is Pompey he's
supposedly the rescue of the Roman
Republic but actually he gets killed by
Caesar
so the rescuer his value goes down to
0.41 in 48 BC so you can see it was very
high here then it went down to 41 and as
we assume that we're not taking care or
we're not we're not keeping track of the
death force here so we assume if you get
close to death there'll be enough
basically static to cause you to die
anyway so if we can get to the last
thing here it's where Caesar is 44 BC
his 1 Caesar was assassinated March 15th
so you can see that his si L value went
down 2.4 won and 44 BC so that's how you
can imagine that things sort of cycling
around and typically the in
three-dimensions vortices dissipate but
in two dimensions they can persist so
this saw triumvirate obviously didn't
persist because every one of the members
were killed or died but anyway it can be
sort of temporarily stable there's a
book called to end vortex method which
shows that you can have vortex stability
of a circular motion with three points
I should mention a couple more things
that uh if you think as a top here as
being uh being the rescuer you can sort
of imagine this as being like thing on
the dollar bill in the back there's like
if you look on the dollar bill in the
back there's a pyramid shape with a
little circle on the top like an eye so
you can think of this as being sort of a
goal that the the US is supposed to be a
rescuer rather than an aggressor or a
victim
although we've had some of the other
thing lately but anyway the other thing
is that uh I don't know if I can show
the picture about when I was at Illinois
Institute of Technology there was a
mathematician named Carl Menger who was
part of the Vienna circle of
mathematicians and I happened to find at
a garage sale a basically a candy plate
or something
which shows a circle it's a circular
with twelve little pictures around the
side and if you look at those twelve
pictures that's actually the finally
dropped it but uh the candy tray was
made by someone by someone in Vienna
Vienna
you know and you can look at the picture
of this so there's so that was one of
the inspirations for being able to
figure this out also there is an
elliptical elliptical tray so it might
be possible to there's a second
triumvirate with Augustus Caesar well I
guess that's the end
[Applause]